one other
very important conversation to have here
New York Post a newly resurfaced video
of a doordash driver who refused to give
a man his food after he only tipped her
eight dollars for a delivery and 2021
has gone viral
the video which has been viewed nearly
one million times on YouTube shows ring
camera footage of the woman yelling at
the man for the seemingly measly tip
when she won when she went on a 12 and a
half mile trip for the food
I think we have that doordash ring
camera footage let's watch
I believe it
I know I could speak to you actually
I'm sorry
I need to speak to you I don't think you
realize where they're coming from so I
need to speak to you
where are the food you ordered the
coming from I don't think you realize
the distance that it's coming from
because then you would never actually
have given what you would give so I
think
you can come and stay face to face
because I drew 40 minutes I drove 40
minutes and it was extremely far and I
got to do early
so I don't think you realize where you
work from
I don't understand all right
Sasha's complaining and then actually
she takes food and drives away she
doesn't give him the food because he
only gave it it only gave an eight
dollar tip that's what blows my mind
about this I mean people are are boldly
people are bold and certain like in the
worst kinds of ways you know there are
times when it's when when uh it's good
to be bold and even good to be
confrontational and and stand up and
speak out and
but these days people aren't very bold
in those sorts of situations it's like
someone's being assaulted on the subway
uh you know or that and that's when we
get into the uh bystander effect and
everyone sits around maybe the recorder
they don't do anything but but if you if
you don't get a tip that for yourself
that you think is big is is good enough
now their people are willing to speak
out about that I can't even
I can't even imagine this I mean I did I
I delivered pizzas for a while when I
was younger and I got bad tips plenty of
times the idea that I would knock on the
door and say excuse me uh this tip's not
good enough I need more I need you to
give me more money
never would have even occurred to me
only because I would have been
embarrassed to do that I would have felt
like uh like a a panhandler doing that
in the not too distant past you know
private citizens used to be largely that
private what's changed well the internet
think about everything you've ever
searched for watched or tweeted on the
internet now imagine all the data being
crawled through collected aggregated by
Third parties into permanent public
records to keep my data private when I
go online I use expressvpn there are
hundreds of data Brokers out there who
sold business involves buying and
selling your data one of these data
points is your IP address data
Harvesters can use your IP to uniquely
identify you identify your physical
location but you can mask your IP
address with expressvpn expressvpn
reroutes my connection through an
encrypted server which makes it more
difficult for third parties to find me
sounds complicated but uh maybe it is on
their end but on our end all you got to
do is just Tap a button on whatever
device you're using and it's really that
simple stop letting people keep logs of
what you do online use MyLink
expressvpn.com Matt walshow today and
get three months free on a one-year
package that's exp resvpn.com Matt
walshow expressvpn.com Matt Walsh show
people are embarrassed about panhandling
these days that's the other problem I
mean you see you see people that uh that
I think we talked about this in a daily
cancellation once uh many moons ago but
this is the thing people they put their
their cash app or venmo or whatever on
their windshield of their car so just
asking anyone who happens to drive by
for money that kind of thing
so I guess it's no surprise to see this
but eight dollars an eight dollar tip
is really good especially for ubereats
or doordash
and this is a problem now now I know if
you're if you if you're an Uber Eats
driver doordash driver uh you know you
don't get it's not like all the money
that's spent is is going directly to you
obviously and so I don't know how much
they actually make from
you know from Uber I don't know how much
of the service fee goes to them versus
the tip
but yeah they need the tip in order to
make this profitable for them but at the
same time it's it's a real problem
because because of the additional
service fees and everything
you're already if you if you order like
a forty dollar meal for two or something
on ubereats it's up to 65 before you
even had to tip in
foreign so it's a it's a problem it is
bringing me more and more steadily to
the conclusion that we just need to be
done with tipping completely it's gotten
way out of hand
everyone asks for a tip now but at the
same time so tipping is expanding it's
becoming much more ubiquitous than it's
ever been before everyone's asking for
it but at the same time everything's
becoming more expensive alongside it
something's got to give I think we just
got to get rid of tipping be done with
it you know many other countries and
cultures they don't do the Tipping thing
I think we just need to
we need to uh get with the times on this
one I don't see any other solution
that'll do it for this portion of the
shows and move over to the members block
you can become a member today by using
Code Walsh at checkout for two months
free on all annual plans hope to see you
over there if not talk to you on Monday
Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]